哇塞 台灣股市今天好誇張喔
大漲1783點
史上最大
一個禮拜內
股市傷溫暖
有冷有熱
你看
一天啊
漲了1783點 史上最大
上禮拜跌了快3000點 一天喔
史上最慘
今天是死貓跳嗎
是台股之後的掙扎嗎
我一直要告訴你 第二
像開流行 我昨天有稍微提到這個東西啊
昨天是名字稍微講錯了
KIMI這個城市啦
大陸這個開源程式啦
AI程式啦
哇 算力不足
這是力多力空
而且聽說是剽竊
中國的cloud的一個程式
是不是真的
我獨家告訴你
這就是AI專家
第三個
被動元件大反彈啦
格系經驗卻大跌
為什麼
這三大重點
有沒有
今天我一次講個夠
而且要更多標股
告訴你
台股今天大漲快1800點
最后收涨在44232点
仿佛上周五大跌3000点
根本就是跌假的
真的太疯狂了
投资朋友们都想知道
台股会V转吗
还会不会持续上涨
突破47000甚至50000点
重点是投资长的标股
今天又大涨喷出了
投资长的好戏登场精彩
这档股票今天开高走高
10点多就90度急了
直接锁上涨停
而投资长的其他股票也都强势反弹
照这个速度来看
是不是就像投资长在节目上说的
10万点是指日可待呢
今年还有机会突破5万点吗
你还没有上车吗
手上没有标股吗
接下来就交给我们经济日报选股冠军
单季188%的记录保持着
同时也是全台湾唯一百万粉丝
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲隆投資長
投資長好
莉莉 各位同學大家好
哇塞 台灣股市今天反彈的
獅子貓跳
反彈沒什麼量耶
幹耶
反彈沒量 哲子怎麼辦
怎麼辦
這量好說喔
哲子說說說說看啦
來 我不唱歌
變成說說說你愛我了
來來
這老哥在那邊聽過
扯遠的
量說了
投資長 量說了
可是今天好消息啊
季線反彈啊
今天對台股最大的意義是
季線
总算在三天内反彈成功
是
季線
应该说在三天内
站上季線
这是台湾股市今天最大的意义
你不要管量跟价
我可以举100个例子
高档爆量
台湾股市继续创新高
我可以
也可以举1000个例子
台湾股市低
你擋的時候
跌升反彈沒有量
還在繼續創新高
量跟價絕對不是一個
絕對的一個數據
一定會怎麼樣
知道嗎
你要相信我
因為就像我講的
昨天好多人喔
雪片般的訊息飛來
哲哲你講得好對
原來你這個看起來算年輕
你這個30年的投資經歷
20年的股市經歷
我說這次昨天不是很多新聞嗎
對
GTF一堆人都買國具
買被動元件
我說他們都忘記
他們為什麼能上來你知道嗎
因為2018年國具的慘具
那時候我還在
我也受傷了
我賺到錢了我也受傷了
那時候2018年的國具
讓很多基金經紀人
受竄 弱件 重件 下馬
你知道嗎
是
什麼意思
很多基金經紀人
就那時候下去的啦
然後離開了基金經紀人這一圈
才讓後面的經紀人有機會上來
所以他們忘記了
他們不知道 沒有經歷過
可不好意思 哲哲都經歷過
哲哲都經歷過
你不要看哲哲看起來年輕
我都經歷過 好不好
所以姜是老的辣 不好意思
好不好 但我不是要攻擊別人
這個誰沒有跌倒過
你知道嗎
我們摸摸頭顧老師
很多人都是老師
很實在
但我不可能難保說
他們一定不會碰跌動元件
不會碰記憶體
可是至少是實在比較重要
到昨天你看到很多人在講賺錢
你聽聽就好了 好不好
那我也跟大家講啊
我說這個只講在前面 你看一下
跟親戚借200萬叫你不要
叫你不要槓桿
借錢也是槓桿好不好
哇 跟親戚有沒有看到
借200萬all in國具
有沒有看到
家人周轉出問題
傻眼 錢不能亂借有沒有看到
有
其實我跟你講喔
你跟親戚借錢還算還好
你跟融資啦
借錢喔
人家把你斷頭
你懂不懂
哇 你要去做地下錢賺
這絕對不改 你懂不懂
你去借那種錢喔
斷頭
或者借錢你壓力很大
你當你斷頭的時候
股票卡在最低點的時候
你要欠一匹股債
你人生就很難重來
所以為什麼這個階段
我的會員朋友們很開心啊
我昨天有沒有講說
你看世界先進
我還反
反彈我想買
我說借一堆股票
我說反彈想買
是不是
是
你看5347世界先進
今天漲不多
但反彈啊
是不是
2%也是錢啊
你看嘛
有些股票
聯發科漲很多
大哥
各位投資票
聯發科我4000多塊賣掉
我1400買耶
你今天就這樣反彈
也是看起來死貓跳
3670元的
聯發科你要幹嘛
就像國巨啦
我跟你講啦
我大膽跟你預告啦
國巨雖然今天爆大量
我看的更多是隔日沖
國巨你不要想他會突破1200了啦
我不敢說100%
你不要說解我的土
打我臉都沒有
我只告訴你機率很低啦
聽了嗎
我身為合法分譯師
我不會說百分之百怎麼樣
或百分之百不會怎麼樣
記得這句話好不好
百分之百怎麼樣或百分之百不會怎麼樣
你一定要記得我邏輯
可是我要告訴你
因為我是合法的
不好意思
你昨天才很多人覺得
哲哲比網紅好
我們至少有執照
而且我們不會偷買股票
沒辦法
我們偷買股票
要被吊牌了
知道嗎
而且哲哲是唯一全台灣法院認證過的
再講一次喔
之前有人要搞哲哲
法院認證過怎麼樣
唯一法院證交所證明
我不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
因為之前有人亂搞
搞個什麼製救會
台北定檢署暗號確骨
110年度他治
1233號直接簽結
簽結就是比不起訴
不起訴等於無罪啦
不起訴你還可以在意
還可以再提起
千結是你沒辦法
至少要兩個檢察官認同
郭哲隆完全沒有罪
兩個以上
我跟大家講
為什麼要講這個東西
忘記了
對
等到國際人才發現
這這二
我絕對不會出貨給你
因為我早就賣掉了
第二個我本來就不會出貨
好不好
我要告訴大家
國際這個不會拉起來了
這個真的沒辦法拉
可是我要告訴大家
講好消息
我不會說百分之百
他還是有一線生機
等到台灣股市
上10萬點的時候還是有機會
來 我昨天講的是有道理
我請問你 你昨天問我4萬3也好
還是4萬點也好
I don't care 反正跌破4萬點
我就說我要買個幾千萬台灣50
我不是這樣講嗎
對
我覺得他強任他強清風佛山甘
所以已經財富自由了
老天爺要多一點錢
讓我回饋社會
讓我捐更多救護車
Find
我已經公開捐兩台救護車了
我這幾年已經公開捐了一千多萬
一兩千萬以上了
公開的 我想是公開的喔
私底下也很多
這個可以做見證
好不好
我今天還有另外一個救護車
我說
請問你最後都到十萬點
你問你要四萬
台湖是會跌到四萬三 四萬二
還是四萬點 很重要嗎
不重要
不是啊 我盤感很強
但我不是每天都一定有盤感
說這個股票一定會跌到哪邊去
這很難抓
你聽懂我意思吧
懂
人家說
你今天那麼強
那你告訴我明天會跌到哪邊去
我最討厭聽這種話
盤感不是每天都有的 你知道嗎
我當時他不知道
有時候就不知道 你懂嗎
所以我問你一件事
來看一件事
今天就懂我
說什麼
真的耶
我應該昨天就買你的股票
金財就會暫停了
你自己看
我再把它改一下
這五年的報酬率你看
如果有10%
10%
台灣50的報酬
就做不到10%
對 台灣50啦
好不好
台灣50跟台股的年化報酬率
應該基本上是一致啦
相關係數應該只好高到98%
台股啊
如果用10%的報酬率來看的話
對不對
從那個差不多43000喔
是不是今天說多少點
今天說44000
是不是很快
真的
所以我說一年10%不難吧
我說你看過一年後才47000喔
我是過一年後才47000喔
其實今年只要47000喔
好
我用10%報酬率來看喔
我第九年就可以10萬點了
沒錯吧
沒錯
我用13.8%
台灣50這23年來23年夠久了吧
23年已經夠久了吧
一個人23年都很老實
一個人23年都可以13.8的報酬算厲害吧
他23年來台灣50的報酬都是13.8%
如果按照這個平均的話
第七年就10萬點了
我用這5年來台灣50這5年來都29%很高
29%的報酬喔
每年漲29%喔
4年
從現在開始4年內
這麼快
就可以12萬點
請問你你告訴我10萬點的4萬點的乘以3倍吧
就是你1000萬其實你好好做賺3倍不難
我要前面的意思我是合法分析師
我不一定
只是你們根本就不懂什麼是AI啊
很多人根本不懂啊
就連很多台積電工程師也不一定懂啊
你們一天會像我一樣問問題
AI問問題
我跟你講我問問題問很仔細我都把它當作
像這樣等一下今天要請假
他說我看一下GEMAN來
然後我說Jimmy你要進去去立啊
我這個好像中二眼 很厲害
因為之前我用Jimmy來
治好他的那個治癒神經治療
真的喔
譬如說我譬如說
像檀固醇藥
像檀固醇
像檀固醇是這樣子喔
血管為什麼很多會中風
就是因為年輕的時候
你沒有把檀固醇降好
我大概從差不多39 38歲的時候
快說出我的年紀
我開始就吃檀固醇的藥
因為我知道
果然這幾年有文獻出來
檀固醇越低越好
譬如說我吃EZ
還有Starding
還有什麼紙的
罐紙的還是什麼紙的
林子
林子的
林子的 對對對
這提供藥給我的
不是 我現在你幫我買的
難怪你知道
你怎麼知道
林子的
我現在你幫我買的
這一藥 林子的最新的
還有那個
PSCK9
打的對不對
兩個月打一次的
我講一講我好痛
這邊很痛
欸 我看這有什麼東西
喔 沒事
昨天這邊好像有個紅包
我這種四種藥
我要跟他配
譬如說我昨天肌肉痠痛
我來跟他查一下
你知道為什麼肌肉痠痛
因為有Starding嘛
然後我說不對啊
你知道為什麼不對 我就問他喔
我說不對啊
那個問題是我以前已經把Starding
就是那個死丁類的藥啊
最老的就是那種降臨無尊藥
我說不對 肌肉痠痛啊
他說這個肌肉痠痛應該是那種
大腿 小腿啊
我說沒有啊
我感受我以前一直以為重訓
後來發現我就會自我測試
我停藥後我就覺得很舒服了
他說那個應該就是Starding類
然後我說不對啊
那為什麼Starding
我已經減半劑量
已經好幾年沒有發作了
為什麼這樣子
我就問他說
那是不是這四種藥裡面
我最新買的那個
凝子德
因為凝子德是這一年來台灣才上市的
是不是凝子德
然後才算他怎麼樣
Starding讓我的那個
也太為肌肉痠痛
他說錯了
凝子德不會讓你肌肉痠痛
可是凝子德
如果再搭配Starding
降膽固程的藥
會讓你肌肉痠痛加倍
大概乘以60%
真的喔
Jemilad 跟你講的
你告訴我醫生
有些醫生還不一定知道這個事情喔
你知道嗎
我去問了醫生
我希望醫生不要看我的節目
那時候我就是用那個
譬如說Studdy
我是用美百樂的
現在台灣已經沒有停藥了
我說欸
類似他有其他懸弥藥
然後結果換個瓶子
他叫我抽血了以後
他說哎呀 你是因為零子的
不是 我就問Jemilad
他說不是
是因為你換了瓶子
也是Studdy內
可是這個瓶子呢
會讓你肝指數變高
他以為肝指數變高是零子的
結果Jemilad 他說不是
我查過相關文獻的
所以我告訴你
我很喜歡問這東西
哦哦哦哦
因為我配這些藥嘛
我喜歡把膽固醇降很低啊
降到下20級
好 我現在膽固醇降到20級
壞膽固醇20級
你們看你們沒有人比我還低吧
可是心臟內科現在都做這件事你聽得懂我還說什麼我扯遠了我還要告訴你有些醫生他很忙他每天看100 200個醫生要看100 200個醫病人可是他覺得加這個藥減這個藥他有這個新的藥物
不是
你看我今天肌肉痠痛
我想說奇怪
為什麼我吸力量減少
因為我配新的藥
配這新的藥
他不會讓你肌肉痠痛
只是原本的藥
濃度會變高
喔 這個也是
可是你前提是你要問問題
是
是不是很驚訝
所以有些藥會交互作用
它上面配方好像也沒寫那麼清楚
一般藥也不會寫那麼清楚
欸 投資長要是沒有問Gemini
那你就永遠不知道為什麼
我永遠就一直肌肉穿痛啊
對啊
是啊 真的啊
我們明明就已經減少劑量了
是啊
所以我就想說
那就兩個一件事吧
要把原本凝脂的就不要吃了
或者是再把它Study內的美白熱
再降低一般的劑量嘛
我是要告訴你說
一般醫生也不一定答出來這東西
因為藥學作用太複雜了
是
我不是瞧不起醫生
醫生很專業
只是他是你好輔助的對象
我講都是某一個東西
其實我一直跟大家在演一件事
基本上我也不是瞧不起現在的老師或醫生
我覺得我都很尊重他們
只是現在如果一個智三夠的 邏輯夠的人
基本上他從小學到大學
他都不需要學校教育了
不需要
因為他會問JMAR
他只要有課本的課題
然後就問JMAR為什麼這樣解答
JMAR答不懂
你再問他為什麼你這樣回答
你懂嗎 很恐怖啊
你剛剛跟講那個要學的作用
你告訴我怎麼辦
或者有些的疾病
你告訴我你知道嗎
譬如說感冒有很多種
有些感冒是那種
其實你是那種病毒式的感冒
或者馬上的
我突然問今天是非常專業的
有些感冒是會死人的
你要配上你的一些其他的作用
或其他的感覺
是
感冒發燒
或者你皮膚某個地方紅腫之類的
那種可能是什麼壞死
肌肉壞死或什麼的
這些東西等到你去問醫生的時候
你還要問對科
可是醫學上它可以幫助你很多東西
我不知道你們有沒有這種感覺
因為講我就覺得我很愛它
我講那些東西
我會講很多東西
接下來講的
那個以前
百年網路上討論
百年的數學家猜想
現在用Gamman去HPT
直接把你回答出來
回答個幾十分鐘就回答出來
我跟你講你們都
我講這些東西之後
我越講越多就覺得
我覺得我是全台灣唯一少數
可以講什麼是AI的分析師
我是跟你說真的
為什麼
因為他們有本事就第一年
來在你們這次底下留言
我那時候台灣股市大概2.2的時候
我說AI股會漲一年
後來開始漲的時候
我說AI股會漲三年
剛好現在第三年了
我在跟你講
AI股再漲三年
漲六年以上
再三年嗎
再三年就是要到十萬年
因為它進步太快了
我想AI它是不用休息的你知道嗎
AI是不用休息
再漲三年好不好
就是我一直要跟大家講
再漲三年
記得我這些東西好不好
好不好
這都是我之前預告的
所以我為什麼有資格講這些東西
所以為什麼我財富自由
因為我投資我都看很長
我沒得看你很短的啦
你知道嗎
確實可以取消學校的教育
真的啊 真的可以啊
所以學校還是不能完全取代
學校是取代
不能取代是人與人之間的溝通
你知道嗎
那我要告訴大家
我看很多年輕的朋友
一一好像也會有
我不知道有些人
你們不要什麼心事跟那個Jimmy來講
你要講的時候你要中立跟他講
不然他會放大人情緒
你很悲觀的人
一直問他悲觀的事情
他會說對 就應該這樣做
你很樂觀的他告訴你你就這樣做
你懂嗎 要忠勵一點 好不好
這應該要從命百歲
應該要活過破百歲
現在已經有人講了啊
醫學家要講了啊
不是醫學家
那個諾貝爾的得主啊
說十年內
人的平均壽命就會大幅延長到
150歲
但那邏輯實在有問題啦
這個要平均150歲
要50年後證明這件事嘛
他說以後可以平均啊
就是可以突破這些壽
可以突破這些壽命的善限啊
好不好
好 來
這好
像止血藥我吃力不頓
啊你有一些
其實他很
就像高血壓的藥你知道嗎
我之前也有親戚這樣
就是不吃高血壓的藥他就不舒服
其實高血壓有幾十種藥
你懂不懂
都是一樣
你可以一個問一個問一個
就見不來好不好
AI是要訓練的
沒有跟他對話很容易胡說八道
沒有錯
所以自己要聰明
盡量中立的講話就好了
好不好
來
今天大展聊天室觀看人數
明顯少很多
我很多的粉絲很多是渣男渣女
都利用泽泽啊
需要我的時候說愛泽泽
不需要我的時候連看都不看
都這樣子
100萬裡面很多渣男渣女
我習慣了好不好
除了你們渣男渣女
你們只要不要亂罵泽泽
亂怪泽泽
當個渣男渣女我可以接受
好不好
我有搬出到你就OK嗎
退休為年齡不就要往後了嗎
怕
我跟你講
我又怎麼樣
可是喔 我跟你講 我賺的錢又夠多了
要退休我馬上可以退休
為什麼退休
第一個 公司還有很多人 我得需要幫忙
很多人叫我不要退休
我跟你講 我的座位名叫什麼你知道嗎
我的座位名叫做
人活著就是為愛自己的人努力
愛我的人越多我越努力
第二個 工作延後一點沒什麼不好
現在很多人提早退休的
現在股票跌了很緊張 你知道嗎
第三個 延後退休
我跟你講啊
延後老人痴呆啊
好不好
平常心
只是說你的工作量不要太大就好了
好不好
你們如果不是像我家工作狂
愛者的今天特休才跟到直播
好像之後跑去過各位三小孩
對我之前那個
不是那種就是三行走勢嗎
現在做走勢2018年出現一次喔
對不對
所以你不要覺得2025
2026年一次喔
2018年就一次了
然後在2022年也有一次
好不好
2022年 2023年好不好 OK嗎
這是韓運股
是
再來今年2026年
2022年我覺得我比較樂觀一點點
因為當台灣股市上10萬點的時候
國際也不會那麼慘
這樣能不能懂 OK嗎
我這簡直是
按照台灣50的報酬率
4年內就好
平均報酬率7年內就10萬點
7年
所以台灣股市基本上是7年到
4年內會10萬點
我賭5年內會10萬點
我就是比較保守一點
但又不會太保守
不會太樂觀
但也不會太悲觀
最悲觀是九年內
10%報酬太扯了啦
10%報酬我就不可能啦
好不好
所以我跟你講最差啦
我說不太可能啦
不要說不可能
所以我跟你講
你看我剛到現在
我就走走
按照你們開始講國標
其實就講我
前提是AI嘛
你知道嗎
很多人問我是AI
台灣股市漲很多
台灣股市十萬點
他們沒有我這個邏輯啊
我能讓我 你一聽就知道
我是問AI 問很多問題有沒有
對不對 沒錯吧
是不是
是 好不好
來 有人說夜盤又噴了 我看
夜盤又長138點
沒有叫又噴了啦
好不好 長1783點
好不好
泰神 全台灣最懂的藥品的分析師
一般藥師他也不一定懂
他要查在交互作為他很難查
其實現在都可以查他的 你懂意思嗎
降膽固醇要做什麼運動
降膽固醇最好的是吃藥
不要想太多 好不好
當然飲食也有差
但不會差很多
你就記得一件事
降糖菇醇藥
把它用保養就好
那個血管就像連輪一樣
你知道嗎
遲早會堵塞的
OK嗎
以後更長命百歲
我跟你講更長命
你的血管用了幾年
你懂不懂意思吧
你不要這樣講
你這個買個家
你久沒有清理
都有灰塵你知道嗎
對
你血管用了一百多年
用八九十年
怎麼可能不會堵塞
所以減少要堵塞
這樣懂不懂
OK嗎
哲哲
我好怕专美金有点骗人
涨高是不是要出货
哦 我跟你讲
这个就是你们这不懂
你们这很多小白
我问你件事
国局为什么涨
跌生嘛 废话
懂不懂
啊 花生金为什么跌
涨太多了好不好
这一波要更没什么跌到好不好
懂不懂
专美金有什么跌
哎 它这一波没有什么跌到
哎 你们看清楚好不好
专美金这样叫什么跌吗
哎 你们不要闹啊
你們看一下2327
國巨這種跌吧
欸
國巨還算還好喔
請問你華新科怎麼一回事今天來跌
天哪
華新科從645元打腰斬是320幾耶
再打個八折
不要開玩笑了啦
打四折
不止喔
比四折還低耶
打三八折啊
三八折啦
真的很三八啦
打三八折
100萬變成38萬啦
你有多少錢農資
然後斷頭關關的啦
這種股票為什麼今天
這種股票
你看今天這種什麼收紅K
所以還是跌收紅K
因為跌很深啊
5483中美金沒有悲觀的噴錢啊
我想你是怎麼拉回買
我告訴你喔
今天還破底
我太開心了
我有說過這個缺口碰到我想買
我今天能不能買
我告訴你我今天要買啦
買多少錢
我管你
這我會員的權益啊
你如果今天中美金都受不了
我告訴你一件事喔
我中美金會員如果沒記錯
除我今天這一批
喔沒有沒有沒有 我全部都賺錢
因為我今天買的也有拉起來
是
是不是每一筆都賺錢
我裝美金每一筆都賺錢
你裝美金會緊張會賠錢的
那通通都不是我會員
你就典型的花省小錢賠大錢啊
這之後為什麼百萬本是
因為準啊
這之後為什麼會員人數最多
我會員很多喔
抱怨完以後
過幾年就重新愛我
這真的欸
那些什麼自救會在那邊亂搞你
那真的是他們都被那其他老師騙了
是不是 被那其他人騙了
是不是 好像你很壞一樣
那欣欣賣在70元
現在漲到了1000多元
今天 就算今天點停版啦
欣欣對不對
欸 我那時候被人家罵欸
幸好法院認證啊
你看今天還800多元
30倍
你看那些人參加什麼自救會
結果人家說 欸 嘖嘖
真的 我幸好那時候聽一半
那些人講你壞話
我看一看去你真的是一個好人
當然是好人
你看全世界最爛的股票
不是什麼星星
也不是什麼台灣50
也不是台積電
也不是什麼
也不是國巨
國巨好歹也漲了一倍以上
到現在為止
是嗎
00687B
我00687B
然後每天看著他看著很圈圈
看著他都在講麻髒話
你知道嗎
真是白癡的我
1.74億的放在現在
錢卡著
比定存好一點
你懂我意思嗎
嗯
真的啦
你真的很覺得嗎
為什麼不出
誰叫我白癡說我沒賺2000萬我就出了
然後我就要怎麼樣
我就要退出股市啦
沒有我很喜歡股市
那唯一的辦法怎麼樣
就不要出啊
就臉皮厚一點不要出就好了
可是至少沒有說謊話
1.74億美債換到現在多少
至少賺到4億5億了啦
那時候是1萬7耶
1萬7耶
至少賺到4億了啦
少賺了2億多
投資長是守信用啦
真的 信用兩億多
所以怎麼有人會覺得說
會質疑哲哲的誠意
說哲哲 你有沒有給人家拿錢
法院證明的
唯一還法院證明 千節的分析師
人在坐 天在看
比救護車也是我捐最多
至少業界分析師最多
那我也不知道臭美
我歡迎業界分析師不只跟我比績效
比捐的錢
大家一起做善事
好不好
像哲哲一樣 越捐錢越多
這樣好不好
好
所以我跟你講啦
要記得就是 啊哲哲講這幹嘛
當然講這很重要
你看的分析師每天給你展停板
然後是假的要幹嘛
所以要先有誠信再看績效
不要傻傻被人家賣了
看一下前幾天還有在賺錢的分析師
你自己想看
你要不要參加行列
好不好
你看 昨天很多人講啦
你看為什麼要講到國具
主動型ETF都是這樣子啦
多膽主動型一天府輪重災區啦
都沒有出啦
我還在強調一件事情
我們要丟他們
我主動型一天府他們壓力很大
他們也沒出
所以有時候你不要怪說
有時候沒動
我最近我還比較靈活
國劇我也出掉
然後那個也出掉
那個什麼
年發科也出掉
然後2408 南亞科也出掉
則而南亞科今天長
長得我又不能追
我不能昨天出
我昨天破線
則而你被騙線了
I don't care
我專60發不能走喔
我一定要賺賣最高點喔
我聯發科也不是賣最高點
那會影會怪我嗎
不會
不會啦
這樣績效到底誰能跟我比你告訴我啊
國際賣那麼漂亮
聯發科賣那麼漂亮都賺100%以上
然後
然後欸欸欸
南亞科是賺60%是這一次賺60%欸
今年加起來一兩百%了啦是要把今年算的南亞科從去年到現在南亞科全部算一下計效給我寫給我或者年3月的時候2月的時候那個表先給我
我現在算的計效表是4月翻多以來的
計效表我還沒有1 2月
我南亞科加一加2 300%了啦
南亞科我真的快要變那個什麼
韓運造子龍一樣啦
我現在是南亞科造子龍啦
七進七出啦
我少好歹說至少三進三出還四進四出啊
什麼事 藍牙科 趙子龍
記憶體 趙子龍
郭子龍
那個我跟你講
為什麼叫他
無栽雕 群聯
你看群聯為什麼今天拉得比藍牙科多
跌比較兇嘛
我說我要買群聯
為什麼要買群聯
我最想的就是
這跟中美今天跌是一樣的
漲很多了
他就會跌
跌很多了他就會反彈
你懂不懂
這是廢話
所以還要含他的基本面跟籌碼面
是
為什麼在1200的時候
整個國際就很不看好
不只1200啦
八九百三十之後我就很不看好了
因為我知道
陳山梅董事長
每次都搞這些
你信不信他還是會搞這些
你信不信
你相信我
還是有可能
好不好
他解直說穿了
就是準備要賣股票
當然我們不能說一定要
就是看起來就是要賣
大家不會等到要
這張賣才OK啊 你懂不懂
我就已經算給他看了
什麼什麼又減資又增資
減資增資減資增資每天完
然後拆除股份
全台灣沒有一個股票
這麼大型股搞這種東西啊
搞這種股權交易的啦
搞這種資本交易啦
真的啦
全程基本上沒有
你看鴻海
鴻海搞是另外一種做法
什麼意思
我子公司上市了
我也更有錢了
可是大家一起賺錢嘛
不是喔
國際有時候搞法是
我賺你不一定要賺
我會講到多少變成
變成好像毀搬人家
我不想毀搬人家
人家至少一等一算厲害
陳大明董事長本來是
跟哥哥一起創業啊
哥哥不想做了
股份賣給他了
他還把他
還併購菲利普的那個
被動員間的部門
搞到原本好像很多人不看好
以小吃大
是不是
硬是把他做起來
厲害啊
以前名機啊
要買新名紙啊
怎麼樣
貪心不足 蛇吞象
這樣還非常評語人家
反而被人家告
不是啊
被動員建的國具還是搞
還是怎麼樣
他還是很厲害啊
被動員建的國具吃菲利普的部門
這已經二三十年前的事情了
對不對
還是把它做得風生水起啊
就是我不得說
為什麼我都記得這件事情
不好意思
我投資經驗三十年了
我每天都在想這些東西
不然咧
所以同樣的幾萬塊會費
你參加我來參加別人比較划算
參加我的比較划算參加別人的
當然是投資長的啊
算了 30年經驗
而且我是全台灣最改砸錢的
你告訴我哪一個人研究部門
砸的錢比我多
我們真的是一個直哉的研究部門
我們我真的每個老師的規模基礎都很大
我們整個公司研究部門
絕對是選投過最大的
那這2月的時候秀的績效表
你們自己看
唉呀 真的是
你看喔 我看你不是秀出來嗎
你看這二月份的時候
二十二月份的時候
你看看喔
是要去個日期好了
南阿科賺204%
從49塊
從去年這時候開始
天啊
143到217有沒有
200多塊你看
我就是三進三出
有沒有
關南阿科賺了快300%啊
這是61%要怎麼樣
是不是
我開心
我驕傲
我有會員抱怨啦
你看機體我都每一個
基本上我都基本上不能說
大部分絕大多數的記憶體都是賺錢走啦
二月份的績效
二月份三月份之前績效
二月份啦
二月份以後我就
就有點空手一陣子
後來績效更恐怖
人在做天在看
我有一點一件事啦
你看這些好不好
國具真的不要再買了
別動元件
你看你要記起一件事
很多這一階段
很多人喔
別動元件不買的原因就是
他想起來2018年的事情
就像我一樣我死不買
我還是不得不買
不然以前有什麼國具啊
什麼華新科啊
什麼信倉店啊
我通通買啊
我買到二手的
三手的
三流的
四流的被動元件
你懂不懂
什麼保護元件什麼都買
都買了都買了
你懂不懂
是
你知道我現在股票一攬囉
是被動元件選股喔
那被動元件20檔的被動元件喔
連被動元件參加那個
我跟你講全台灣沒有分析師
比我了解被動元件的啊
比了解韓運股更強啊
因為我被貝多元俊耍過
我跟你講一件事啊
他很難再創新高了
相信我啦
我已經告訴你們主動型ETF的經紀人
少買他啦
我跟你講
陳奈民總是很難辯啦
我不要辯批評人家
一個人個性很難辯
我從員工管理就知道
你懂不懂
人家就要用首富了
我跟你講一個人個性很難辯
好不好
OK嗎
這跟大家講
這是預言家
這就是一個人的個性難的變
他多少到時候會做一些
稍微有爭議的事情
你記得這句話
有沒有下流的被動員界
一流的二流三流
下流不要再講人家啦好不好
而且這就是被動員界啊
你去問業界啊
根本沒有2018年那時候那麼缺貨
是
根本沒有好不好
技術含量很低啦好不好
今天外資賣4 3 1 還可以展切點
今天空檔回到8萬口
空單
空單好像沒有吧
好像沒有吧
所以我這個
我從那個被關聯金告訴你
參加好會員
你可以趨急並凶
群聯呢
群聯就是老闆一直講話
一直上電視
一直上節目
你知道
有時候就這樣人就很奇怪
你一直上一直上
好像發不得人家買
不然群聯基本面是不錯
你懂意思嗎
好不好 OK嗎
群聯基本面是不錯
所以群聯董事長
你買就買得很實在
跟你講這些東西
好不好
電腦國家我就有機會拉起來了
記得記憶體這些東西還是很重要
那個人沒有
你知道為什麼記憶體很重要
你知道嗎
對AI的電腦而言
最重要是什麼
最重要的是
如果你會算力
算出來以後對不對
會推理人對不對
是
阿如果你一個AI的一個代理人
或你的AI的機器人
你罵記者主人的任何一件事
有什麼用
對不起講話比較粗俗
完全沒有用
對不起我跟講話太粗俗
有什麼用
沒有用
我這樣講人生好就知道
其實我這幾年
我在步入終點以後
我已經在思考人生的意義
像以前我的目標是長命百歲
我現在目標是快樂每一天
能越長生越好 什麼意思
如果我到了80
從70歲開始
我從60歲開始
我每天生病
每天憂鬱
那我不如 60歲
人生就拜拜
你聽得懂嗎
如果這樣子 你聽得懂嗎
了解
我要開心每一天
所以我在想什麼叫人生意義
什麼叫人生意義
人生意義的定義就是說
你要 你人生在這 假設是100歲
你能健康到95歲
甚至99歲 100歲最好
不行 那你其實沒什麼意義
好 第二個
要快樂的時候 同時要怎麼樣
像馬英九總統
哇 以前很優秀
睡太少覺了
你知道 但總統說只睡一個小時
現在變成
老人痴呆 老人失憶症了
你可能知道 最近有一些新聞
看起來應該就是了
不然怎麼公開場合都不見面
我不是要批評他
我覺得很可惜
你看他每天在游泳 我體魄很好
所以第二個重點是什麼
要有記憶
我師固我在
一個人如果
你看回憶啊
所以有時候為什麼很痛苦
有些人失戀會很痛苦
因為回憶那很痛苦
可是也也是因為回憶
讓他記得他是誰
你知道嗎
沒錯
Who you are
Who are you
嗯
你是誰
記憶那你知道你是誰
一樣啦
那AI最重要是記憶啊
這懂的意思嗎
記憶靠什麼
記憶體啊
還有那些SSD啊
最近到時候都會通通缺貨
所以人到時候跟機器人
你分不出來啊
結果我媽媽這樣看AI短片
男的帥女的美啊
是
玩祖賢有沒有看到
現在賣啊
玩祖賢也有人輸
他現在整型醫美啊
是有點
我是覺得有點整過頭
希望他沒看我節目啦
可是他以前心目中
我看到欠你幽默的
之後就好漂亮
他出賣他的什麼
20到30歲的
不是肉體喔
20到30歲的臉
你可以用我的臉
去拍AI的影片
這個也有這種搞頭
所以我看以後AI影片
真的是會取代很多人
真的
所以記憶體
所以我跟你講
五眼佛記
我剛講的醫學傳授這些東西
哇 我跟你講這些東西
你就要有想像力
所以這些股票通通會長這樣
十萬點很正常
我是覺得我也蠻好命的啦
剛好來摩尾以後
這股市就順風順水了
你知道嗎
然後遇上十年一次大多頭
可是整個要運氣好
剛好卡入YouTube
你懂不懂
在YouTube剛好要起來的時候
不然我只能成為百萬粉絲
所以你要相信我看
看未來的一個切入點
那個Line也是我數一數二切入的
Terrygan也是我第一個
全台灣第一個
我每一件事都做第一個
我每一件事基本上都做第一個
你不然去比較嘛
所以我告訴你
這些股票都會噴出去好不好
這些股票都會噴出去
凡軒也是有機會再噴出去
好不好 凡軒看起來都噴出去的
還有3374精彩
太誇張了 精彩這種走線
精彩這個跳空缺口有沒有看到
本來跌下去了 就拉上起來了
精彩這邊的中15很厲害
他一副就是我要讓他上去就上去
我要讓他下去就下去 你知道嗎
精彩太強了 你知道嗎
還有2377微星
我問你一件事
微星你告訴我
就基督線圖有跌嗎
你看喔
它只要下去
一定修下影線
它連昨天都修下影線
你不覺得很扯
是
微星連昨天都沒什麼跌
我跟你講
金彩會是最猛的
微星會是很強
很強勢的反彈一段時間
它會整理非常久
你們要看懂K線
你們看不懂K線
不要
你看的分析是不要講那種
一般節目都在講
重慶南路的書局
重慶南路現在沒什麼書局
書局裡面成本書局
成品裡面書局裡面
技術派的書裡面講的東西
那沒什麼
我叫你實戰派
我直接告訴你
那就是跟你講
以前那些股票看了什麼
突破什麼限圖
然後創新高
我直接告訴你
維新這個
他技術派整理而言
他就是要噴出去的
裡面周知物大國投信
他資金籌碼已經怎麼被鎖起來了
鎖住了
你看
台灣股市昨天大跌
欸 昨...
說說 禮拜五大跌
對
所以禮拜五沒錯吧
禮拜五大跌它是收14k
差點收紅k
昨天三規指數崩盤
是不是
是
它照樣
昨天三規指數崩盤
國際是跌停板的
它照樣留一個非常纏的下影線
它整個區間整理平台
完全沒有跌破
我跟你講
微星是來真的
為什麼很多股票都跌不下去
有時候你說資源
資源你人正看
他有跌什麼嗎
他也沒展什麼展也沒什麼跌
是
我的股票為什麼
資源還算比較弱一點點
可是你看我的股票
可以已經很強了
不論是微星
不論是金財
你告訴我有什麼跌嗎
或中美金
你告訴我有什麼跌
不要鬧了
為什麼我選的股票是低基期
中美金你現在不趕快給他買一買
到時候你會後悔
我跟你講
為什麼
為什麼我現在
我股票這麼多大戶中實務認同他
因為投票股市已經漲到四萬五了
一堆股票漲
欸 你跟我說
欸 你知道為什麼我真的很生氣
賣格里嗎
你要的力量一千四百元或兩千元
講說 哎呦 聯發科再漲一倍
不是 你這快五千元的時候
你跟我講說聯發科漲到一萬點
是幹嘛
漲到一萬元是幹什麼
一檔股票已經漲三倍了
你要想的是怎麼下車
一檔股票短期內就漲三倍
你以為是每檔股票都在台達電是不是
聽懂嗎
懂
一擋股票已經漲三倍了
你要想是怎麼下車
去選擇低低級股票
為什麼我現在績效傲視群雄
你不能說主動行進貼物
可是我要告訴大家
可是最近是運氣好
實力加運氣
不是每天
不是每天都主動保佑我
所以你要趁現在趕快找我
我也沒有要批評別人
可是我最近績效實在是好的要命
所以你要這時候參加我會員
趕快來
我一堆股票都在低低級
好不容易回擋了
回擋也不升了
是不是 好不容易
我昨天講 我說我最想要買的是什麼
中美金
可是中美金回答不多 有沒有講
有
我說我看到世界先進回答那麼多我就買了
世界先進的價格比之前
有沒有 有一個跌停板 你自己看這邊跌停板有沒有看到比之前 跌停板的時候這邊的跌停板有沒有看到比之前跌停板的時候價格還低
沒錯吧 沒錯
為什麼之前跌停板 台積電賣它
所以現在比台積電賣它還差
台積電都說了電源管理IC會漲
電源管理IC缺貨
是應該說缺貨
所以我再給你一個八卦
昨天我就講了 昨天我講的SK講錯了
應該是KIMI
你看大陸這個也是一樣
大陸有沒有看到
KIMI K3 有沒有看到
有
成本啦 我對手的一半啦
美國這些對手一半 這是三分之一啦
那KIMI為什麼成本那麼低
因為他知識真流啊
知識真流這邊寫得不好
我直接告訴你清楚啦
就是我就給
我就比如說我在模仿Cloud
Enthropic的Cloud
是
那我就一直問他問題
一直問他問題
拿著考古題一直問他問題
問他所有問題 問完以後是Copy以後
你可以問他無限問題啊
問完以後Copy以後都已經成本低啊
Copy以後對不對
複製貼上
然後甚至破解理解他的邏輯人力
然後等於複製貼上
這叫真理喔
是
你懂不懂
等於老教授啦
是慢慢的慢慢的有一定的學術基礎
用基礎啦
去解答每一題啦
不是啦
你現在是學生
只用考古題啦
用考古題的了解這些所有的考試啦
所有的教科書
這樣懂不懂
懂
這叫真六技術
來吧
那你看喔
人家說
嗨 Kimmy
What's wrong with you
我是Card 不是Kimi
慘了
因為他是真
因為他可能之前有問這個問題
然後換記
指按複製貼上沒有刪除啊
他的回憶啊
這時候記憶體如果不組
就會換記他是誰了
看玩笑
好 這麼看到沒
為什麼 現在都問題是什麼
現在重點啦
因為算力吃緊暫停開放新用戶訂閱
KIMI K3
KIMI這個軟體
有關C-Dance也好
你懂不懂
他Deep Seek去年不是很紅Deep Seek
對
那你那個輝達大帝嗎
我說說過了
需求無遠佛界
你看啊 喔唷
KIMI來了成本低了 慘了
要被砍架
有嗎
算厲害還是吃緊啊
我管你成本多少
就是怎麼樣
還是需要
還是需要AI伺服器啊
所以AI伺服器的需求會非常非常龐大
只有中國要搞
日本不用搞
台灣不用搞
印度不用搞
搞個開源性的
你把AI被人家掐住喉嚨
自己不會研發
阿布達比不用搞
你不要說了啦
阿布達比唯一厲害
是不是你以後
可以用AI來發展這些遠途的
遠途的一些飛彈
是不是
這麼可怕
這一定要啊
如果我是他
我一定要發展AI啊
不然我怎麼跟伊蘭
我怎麼跟伊蘭PK
也是
是不是
你看伊蘭現在越搞越大了啊
我現在唯一的隱憂是美伊戰爭
說話說唯一唯一有美伊戰爭
幸好川普很...很...很...很凹啦
我記得他11月之前
他還是會退爛啦
你懂不懂
只是現在剛好美軍有幾個人上完
台灣股市現在沒有什麼憂慮
最大的憂慮就是美伊戰爭
因為美國的石油庫存一直在減少
原油價格沒有上去
這很重要是美國一直
各大國家一直把他們的戰略庫存
戰略庫存石油一直試出去
那談下去怎麼辦
還是很恐怖啊
立正的意思嗎
這是台股最大的隱憂
台股最大的隱憂是通貨抹戰
不然沒有隱憂
那這隱憂好在
我覺得川普會推拉
記住就好了
台股現在最大的隱憂是
每一戰爭看起來要談和
要和談了 要搞定了
又開始七大
這是最大隱憂
那最大隱憂的結束
我覺得也是川普會結束
只是我覺得
就是我剛才講的
每十字軍東征
宗教的戰爭
宗教種族
尤其宗教 種族還好
宗教的一個不同
為什麼
因為宗教很容易
很容易吸腦一個人
這樣吸腦兩個字
會到時候被他罵
很容易影響一個人的腦袋
你聽懂嗎
只是什麼都看 你知道嗎
那時候還會看的
最近之前有一個電影就是說
一個精神科醫生
要宣判
美國 德國 納粹的將軍
這些人 元帥
他們是不是壞人
不是 他們都覺得他們不是壞人
他們都覺得他們殺人
是為了崇高的影響
他們為了自我合法
他們自我合法他們做壞事的一個意圖
會合理化
不是說天生就喜歡內代人
他們覺得沒有 我為了更好的國家
為了更好的環境
你知道好像那是台灣農捲風
八點展中連續劇
真的
每個人都羅生門
每個人都是為了更好的自己
更好的未來
所以我要講的是那種宗教
就是我
我是對的
另外一個人你覺得
美國也是覺得它是對的
伊蘭你覺得它是對的
你懂嗎 變羅生門了
這個兩個變代溝了
這種東西很難搞定
這是我覺得台灣股市最大的隱憂
其他沒有隱憂
我想真的沒有人能像我講這些
總體經理講那麼清楚
你看我今天是不是可以講20分鐘的股票
我也沒講多少
我直接告訴你
我這些股票通通讓它噴出去
我看實單裡面至少有巴掌
我覺得大噴特噴
我非常有自信
因為你看來看起來
是我股票最噴
你看看
我把拉克賣掉
我一定都不後悔
我們看下去 它也賺204% 還60幾%
我要買新的股票
但是我們可能把藍氧科的資金拿去買
拿什麼
拿去買群兩個位
只是股價一個1000多塊 有些人不挺喜歡
所以我還借股票要噴出去
要找你啊 世界金錢趕快來啊
帆軒也是一樣 噴出去 現在幾分啊
6196帆軒 你看我的股票
你看一下我的股票
看下我的股票 看下帆軒
有破底的感覺嗎
沒有吧
你再看一下別人的 292也好
為什麼台觀店是不是
也好 有沒有看到
是不是
這好像是00981A最多的
我不覺得有些主動型貼幅有
金居你看
你看金居也是很慘 有沒有看到
有沒有看到
有
金居也好
從750跌到350
你看一堆股票這種跌法
可是你在看一次我的股票
維新你看起來有要跌嗎
沒有啊
還是要噴出去 看起來是要噴出去
對
3374精彩
看起來是要噴出去喔
要再次噴出去 沒錯吧
沒錯
我的股票線圖都跟人家不太一樣喔
以前最強勢的股票
CPU一堆股票
善權看怎麼樣
善權也很慘啊
為什麼
大力官說CPU
雖然他們兩個做的
CPU不太一樣啦
雖然都是CPU
毛利益很難說啊
你聽懂吧
我本來就說CPU是炒作
你們自己不理我
你看CPU跌那麼慘
你看我基本上善權
我只買過一段時間
我見好就收
CPU基本上我沒在買
我很少買買了就膽在跑
我從頭到五我就不看好這個基本面
我講話都很實在
我國際的跟你講是
我還在預測前面
人不會改 很難改
就像我這樣講
他可能聽得很癢癢癢癢癢癢癢
不好意思喔
可是問題是在利益擺在前面的時候
國際可能會選擇是利益
不會選擇你們
我不是要毀謹
我就是可人
好不好 可人
我也希望他不要這樣做
因為賞物很可憐
好不好
如果我不去賭
他會不會大發慈悲
這是不會這樣做或會這樣做
你聽懂嗎
懂喔
我選擇的是我去買別的股票
你懂不懂
1800男股票
任君選擇
你知道假設
女生你是1800個男朋友
還會被人家罵
太花心了
1800個女朋友
不是股票1800男股票
隨便你選
不會有人覺得花心
你要選得好 選得妙
真的是股神在世
對不對
1800男股票幹嘛
可以選一堆股票
你看我一堆股票都很強
是不是
是不是 我這樣說沒錯吧
沒用
六四八八環球金
很慘
你也看拜託
這種走勢要慘嗎
不慘啊
今天是達到季線
這邊差不多可以找買點
差不多可以找
不慘
他每一次都在25%
25%
欸今天1200喔
差不多又25%了欸
欸
沒錯
你看1600乘上0.75嘛
25%嘛對不對
對啊 就是1200啊
欸 又1200咧
欸 你不要喝
還有咳嗽
是不是要回到25%
是
欸 又買一點了喔
可是這裡面是造成什麼樣的中食物
好厲害
這回到25%
對不對
這回到25
這邊25對不對
對
今天是25了
我們明天要找人買了
應該找人買了 我跟你講
他在疊
沒錯吧
沒錯
2529 2529
你看他就跟國劇不一樣
你看我可以清遍分清
清遍
那個明白的分辨清楚
誰是回彈30%到35%
聽懂嗎
誰是適用回彈35%的三五法則
誰是適用255法則
回彈25%
誰是適用就算回彈35%也不能買
我還是說國劇華興哥不能買
關這些你就參加我會員的啦
再看一下我們績效
來 這是截至今天的績效喔
這樣幾分啊
要結束了
剛才有剛才那些股票的績效
目前為止環球金132
金財95%有沒有看到
帆軒51有沒有看到
中美金36
有沒有看到
中美金我們比較低的
第一次成本就在175元附近
微星賺錢
有沒有看到好不好
紅海雖然是230的
高膽也有買 我要老實跟你講
我們是選比較低的成本
會開始成本
年發科4000多元賣掉
10千多元賣掉
賣一半
3800元也賣另外一半
平均賣到4千多塊
國劇賣得很開心
國劇以後我才能有聯發科嘛
是不是
國劇聯發科
應該是國劇聯發科
差不多時間
國劇聯發科
至少國劇可以換成環球金嘛
對不對
那時候講得很清楚嘛
你看兩亞科大專 61%
我的股票真的太猛了
所以你去想清楚
想明白你要怎樣的分析是
好不好
最後看大家一件事情好不好
這股票真的很看跌
我看到
CP和這台本益比好幾倍
以前一些別人投顧的
每天講CPU
跌下去都不關他的股票
每個都魔術師啦
被動元件前任其他投顧很多老師
不像我們能夠投顧老師真的是很實在
但我不會講是誰
因為我們在看
我都知道他們的手法
只要暫停都有
跌停都沒有
你相信喔
你告訴我
我出去參加會員
我不相信好不好
好不好
所以你去想看你要怎麼分析師好不好
大盤會V轉嗎
大盤
跌太深了不太會V轉
但會慢慢漲
好不好
大盤看起來如果三天內
這一次喔
我看得出來
這一次對不對
如果我們
這個不要一個禮拜內
沒有再破這個底部的話
我覺得機率蠻高不會破
那有可能就是慢慢的上去慢慢上去
好不好
我原則很簡單
到四萬點
我就揪個幾千萬買台灣股息
老天爺送錢給我
沒有
不好意思你們賺更多
直接噴出去了
我覺得不要去預測這個行情
我覺得不太會V傳
但是台灣股市幾年內
四年內
30萬點
我非常有信心
居然如此你還不敢加入我行列
歡迎來一家旋 0806 8085
或者加入LINE 私訊我
恭喜我們 猛街精彩賺的賺什麼
95%是不是
今天精彩你自己看一下
還直接所產停板
這麼看壓的股票
賺那麼多錢股票
還有環境賺那麼多錢股票
全台灣現在計下誰最好的
不是是嘖嘖我嗎
趕快來一家旋 0806 8085
08066 8085 8085
也加入LINE 或者加入LINE 私訊我
告訴我說嘖嘖 我要參加會員
可是会不会多少
我捷径我所能来帮你赚大钱
谢谢各位 拜拜
谢谢大家